i want to bring angela over there with
me so he can just meet a friend first
and if things go well then he can meet
my family
if things go well with my family then we
can get married
i like that i believe in slowing down
especially because this is a lifetime
commitment
you don't want to make the same mistake
twice
[Music]
my best friend angela has offered to go
to jordan with me and i am so relieved
i just ended one bad marriage i'm not
gonna be pushed into a potential second
one
especially since there are so many
things still up in the air
and i know angela will tell it to me
straight she's the person that i trust
the most
now that part with angela coming that
was a surprise to me but that was a
pleasant surprise
but i'm still concerned about the family
because of what happened in the past i
mean
it seems like he's getting more
independent and
his parents aren't going to be a problem
because he said that he separated from
them
he was really close with his family so
what caused the separation
he just decided to move out because he
needs to be his own man
okay so that means he's abandoning a lot
it's good that he'll do that for you but
it's also important that he does it for
himself because if not he'll hold that
against you later on
okay i don't know in the long run it
could be a problem is it
really worth going back to jordan for
you